okay
what up i gotta put on my headphones
okay guys i'm just doing a lot oh [__]
i'm just doing a live stream um and i
figured you guys would just give me
stuff to react to while i am
live because i didn't have anything to
react to today
so i'm gonna just wait till my people
get on
here wait for your requests
okay let's see i'm about to pull up the
comment section on my
phone because i don't actually know
okay okay i'm looking at the comments
now
okay i think you should react to forgive
be you
[Music]
low
i hope i didn't google anything
embarrassing recently
um
[Music]
little snook i don't see anything
that has like a lot of views
okay i don't see anything it's the first
one
ah i get kind of
it only has 21 views if this is your
music
i don't want to do this to you i don't
i've had a lot of people send me their
music
and i i don't know if i want to do this
to you you seem like a nice guy
um
yeah i
okay tommy ghetto
karan okay let's do that i'm like
kind of afraid that i google something
embarrassing
so don't mind
my search history i don't think i have
anything that embarrassing but you never
know
all right can you guys hear the sound
okay let me i'm just gonna get it okay
before i go
so i'm gonna just play the sound for a
second
you hear me and the sound
i've had issues that's why i want to
make sure that i get an okay before i
keep going
um
okay i don't i'm gonna just assume you
guys can hear everything
one time
[Music]
i don't understand what's happening over
and over again
i'm a little lost yo when you're here
talk to the south side you're here talk
to the team
your [__] fear prince and respect it
praying for you slow [__] imma
break it down ella
supreme was a businessman and pranks was
the killer remember you used to push the
bulletproof beard
i sat back and beep [__] can you guys
understand this
i can't i can't even a little bit
easy had the whole projects working for
50 or 500
as a youth all i ever did was sell fact
i used to idolize okay so he's saying he
sold drugs as a kid that's not something
i'd recommend
hurt me to my heart to hear that [__]
snitched on pat how you
okay no i've heard a lot about this you
cannot snitch
and like i don't want to say the hood
but i can't think of anywhere else to
just
any other way to describe it but
snitching is bad and all the rap songs
i've listened to
bad not a good thing caught my first
year since i had the forerunner to see
the five and the three used to drive his
truck through the hood dragging jet skis
from general wallace to baby wise
don't be surprised how freely i thought
our names are guys who there were pies
like l.a and wise
hell got shot in the net they told us
connect them [__] who shot him gotta
put some bricks [__] dominicans
turned
[Music]
oh that's so clever lord forgive me for
i have sinned over and over again
oh my gosh this song is four minutes and
31 seconds what are they doing to me
that's a giant ass house
[Music]
princeton righteous from hillside with
the mole on his nose throughout my
struggles in the hood
i started learning life's a [__] with a
pretty face what's she burning
man imma get cheesed like chad's then
with the whips like seaguar
gamble all the time like country curly
head princess
[Music]
standing divided they fall round here
shook [__] they keep it in motion
come around here with your roller you
can get robbed like ocean lord
okay so he's saying do not bring nice
things around here you
will get robbed uh he's also saying that
when like people go
against each other and like argue with
each other and stuff
it's not as effective
as if you work together great
couldn't catch them dirty so settle for
tax evasion
[Music]
oh no oh dear what's going on
what they was about the twins was from
quays but got crazy crane without po
throughout my time i heard tales of
heimi
frenchie jamaican poorly ducky cauli
rodney bumpy chick [__]
i have no idea who any of those people
are at all
a lot of [__] float away outflow but
ain't been in the game all night so
don't know who i know
writing rhymes is the best way i express
how i feel if i ain't rich by 26 i'll be
dead or in jail
coming up i don't sipping too much so
he's saying if he doesn't make it by 26
years old
he'll probably be in jail or dead um i
think
i'd like to say there is an option three
you could just keep trying
um but who am i to tell you how to live
i guess
and if you watch the news you see
players in this game they lose i'm
forgetting lefty jazz
pretty tony and lance had luke mel's son
trainee moneybags
in a conversation over shrimp and
lobster and benny highness hurt chico
stop boxing they started rob mcdinners
shout out to clarence and clutch bob's
ray
blackwell if the flow don't kill you the
magwell
okay the chorus is catchy but i have a
hard time understanding most of this
song
oh no oh no
[Music]
don't do it don't do it don't kill him
don't do it over and over
[Music]
damn well i'm gonna give that song
a two maybe a one out of five i just
didn't like it
i think it's cause it's an older song
and i don't like older music
that much 2017 not that old um
okay what am i going to react to next
let's see
tom mc
donald if i was black okay
it looks like i've looked that up before
have i heard it before
if i was black probably wouldn't but
anyone who's white cause that slavery
would honestly always be on my mind if i
was black
probably wouldn't ever wanna drive cause
if police pull me over i might look
around and die if i was black
i won't lie i'd be scared to walk at
night
oh this is not
where i thought this was going i'm not
gonna lie to you the neighborhood is
tripping like i'm out committing crimes
i be pissed at all these cracker rappers
singing about my life stole my music
store my style give it back it
is
just wasn't expecting this just look at
the facts we don't stand a chance one in
three is locked away
over half don't know they dead see white
privilege and a money thing but it's
white people who are running things
y'all benefit from your coloring my
pigment produce
white lies white houses white guys white
washing my brothers my sisters my
culture while i'm watching
if i was
i feel so uncomfortable i could probably
hate myself
they say racism made me racist and i am
not the one to blame
hey y'all won't say it to my face in the
circles you feel safe y'all been using
words they made for us when we were
slaves hey
hey wait whoa i know that was long ago
if i was black i want my reparation
[Music]
okay i have a question the reparations
things i've thought about this
hypothetically let's say they did
reparations
i'm irish right i came from like ireland
would i be a part of that
so if you think i'm broke you will know
when i speak
if i was black it's my face on a t r i
be
underneath no my name extra friend if i
was black i would die
in these streets just to speak in my
mind because i had a dream
if i was black if i was black probably
wouldn't ever do my taxes
why support a government to persecute my
blackness or pay the wage of law
enforcement putting us in caskets okay
i'm not gonna lie to you guys
i hear what he's saying but you should
really do your taxes
you i there are people that go to jail
for a long time
for not doing your tax like you don't
don't listen to that
do your taxes or help to build the
prisons that we trapped in
if i was black i'd be mad people glorify
the trap while we dying every day
fighting for everything we have it ain't
diamond changing racks this is a
systematic plan
they put us in the ghetto gave us hiv
and crack if i was black i'd hate
america appropriate my character
and sell it to caucasians who wish they
were from my area if i was black i
wouldn't give a [__] about the greater
good my grandma can't afford a rent go
gentrified our neighborhood
our lives matter so stupid y'all
hijacking our movement black lives
matter cause we losing innocent youth
the police shootings
if i was black the only role models i'm
shown is the rich black rappers pushing
guns and drugs and hoes yeah
hey y'all won't say it too look
that's a little racist there are
definitely other role models like
like will smith he doesn't do any of
that
that's that's a little racist to me i
mean
i don't i don't want to say it but my
face in the circles you feel safe y'all
been using words they made for us when
we were slaves hey hey
wait whoa i know that was long ago if i
was black i'd want my reparation why'd
you guys do this to me
why'd you do this to me
[Music]
so if you think i'm broke you will know
when i speak
if i was black it's my face on a trip
[Music]
that you ain't allowed okay
what what is going on with that guy's
mouth i was like
y'all never tried to take me down isn't
he just saying like appropriation isn't
okay fist in the air
[Music]
okay i got i got the idea i'm
uh give me the next song guys okay
um
[Music]
all right g herbo statement
um check this out
always always mean what you say
real [__] till i leave elevated do this
rapping [__] with ease i got a brick on
my sleeve you dissing me please compare
me to different emcees stop it
i really am okay so he said you're
dissing me and
i know a thing or two about dissing when
i was younger
that was like yo mama jokes like yo mama
so fat whatever
um in 2021 that looks like
i'm i'm a [__] your girl i would think
yeah that's my guess
this [__] still won't pop it before
twitter was a trending topic
i was on the block with 30 shots and
glocks had the spot hopping
dummy but they acting like they don't
remember that been a leader with that
heater i got right up into that
you can't never take a killing back
whole heart was in the streets okay so
he's saying you can never take it kill
him back so if you kill somebody you
can't take that back i think that's
pretty self-explanatory but
like i think i could have inferred that
without it being a rap
but you know that's just me i had to
leave and get my [__] feelings back
same spot they shot my brother the next
day i'm chilling it i ain't lying they
was winning till we started spinning
backs but anyway
said enough of that let's talk about
this paper let's talk about them jets
yeah let's talk about jamaica asked
about me i ain't never been a fraud i
went hard from the start in my city i'm
a god [__] if you know you know
never been no phony though rolly's for
my brody though so he's saying i've
never been a phony
and that basically means that i'm not
fake
i tell it to you how it is barely no joe
rodeo
heard they looking for me i'm like oh
i'm on the way buying money no i'm
straight i spent 130 k
out the gate they like swerve stay safe
i'm like oh my gosh i love this beat
i love it this beat is fun i can already
[Music]
okay i like his outfit black on black i
think it's cool
[Music]
okay so i he said i could have bought a
rolls royce which is a car
i think um and
instead he bought a four flat so is that
like a apartment like a flat
chicago i'm pro motivation for the
trenches cause i'm pro black
real no limit so we don't play by the
rules how the [__] i catch a case we
bought a school don't be fooled you
[__] fools
on the ground reading comments i'm like
ooh cool
so they want me to lose i can't break
like i'm bulletproof
okay they always say this in raps
they're like they want me to lose
but i guarantee nobody cares about you
that much like
i'm sure some people don't like you and
aren't excited when you do well but
nobody's sitting around just like
pray what do they say praying on your
downfall yeah
and i can't say what i won't say all i'm
gonna say is before fame [__] i've been
the truth
and when you put it on my name you gotta
send some proof they like charge it to
the game
i gotta feel it should be difficult
[Music]
this year you [__] and we get airplanes
next year [__]
show i've been shopping for him
an airplane what the heck we're going to
demand next year
to get all diamonds
[Music]
should i react to now um
it's coming by trippy red okay
oh dear i hate face tattoos
i think face tattoos are so ugly
is this dude like a [__]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
this is the worst song i've ever heard
this is terrible
absolutely terrible
[Applause]
i can't even finish this whoever
recommended this i'm never trusting your
recommendations again
i'm sorry it's it's that's bad that's
just bad i'm not even finishing this
i've never not finished a song before um
all right dmxx it's coming
oh wait
um did i type it weird
i don't i don't see that one
uh dmx
why do i not see it
okay let me look at a different one
[Music]
oh x is coming
i seriously don't see this all right
soul train
um okay wait
soul train by why
wait i don't need the reaction just the
[Music]
video
okay if i gave you all my love
[Music]
baby
um sorry i keep forgetting to make this
full screen
i don't know about this why do you guys
keep recommending
[Music]
we don't feel like we
okay you might not be doing much you
might not be doing much i'm not gonna
lie if you don't feel like we're doing
too much
you might not be doing too much every
time i'm with you
it don't feel like we doing too much
every time i'm with you
i can't give everything to you baby will
you bring it back to me
but i
[Music]
now
why are you doing this to me guys this
this is terrible
terrible oh my god 344
000 dislikes
this guy just made it out to the out the
hood and made it right back
what if i was depressed this could have
been my last
straw this sound like a soundtrack they
would play at the end of a disney movie
i have it listening but listen but what
a effing ratio
my dad actually came back with the milk
while i listened
so he could smack me across the face
wow
corey why would you do this to me i
i don't know how to feel um but
i'm ending this live on that note
because you guys are playing
you're playing with me you're playing
with my emotions
you're pl you're playing that's it
that's all i got to say